did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
life has had 3.8 billion years of
research and development biomimicry is
about copying the best ideas Nature has
come up with in all that time biomimicry
was used in the design of one of the
most iconic structures in the world the
Eiffel Tower the designers of the famous
Tower in Paris took inspiration from a
natural design principle called
structural hierarchy take for example
your femur bone or thigh bone your femur
bone gets its strength from tiny tubes
called osteons composed of even tinier
bundles inside called fibrils tubes
within tubes within tubes when eiffel
was looking for lightweight strength for
his tower he applied a similar
structural hierarchy of trusses within
trusses within trusses to achieve it the
towers curving support structures also
appear in nature your femur bone is wide
on top and then narrows as it goes down
into your leg when Eiffel was designing
his tower in Paris he looked at how the
bone was reinforced along lines of
stress he realized that if he turned
that upside down he could have a very
strong base that would handle any kind
of winds that might hit the tower so
when you look at those crossbars on the
Eiffel Tower understand that those were
inspired by the same lines of
reinforcement that are in your bones
for more episodes of things like a tree
subscribe to the wired Channel